once upon a time there were two trolls
they saved the world pretty cute right
not to me
I'm the type of cloud that goes for this
sort of thing Edie what poppy and branch
didn't know was their world was a lot
bigger than they thought a lot lot lot
bigger there are other kinds of trolls
our ancestors created six streams each
for a different type of music rock
country techno classical funk and piece
of news honey and daddy there's a world
full of other trolls how different can
they be I'm gonna unite the sixth string
by the end of my world tour I'm gonna
turn all the trolls into rocks on she
wants to destroy us we need to unite the
trolls to save all music let's sing them
the most important songs in the history
of music this ought to be good I knew it
who let the dogs out too far prepare for
battle
oh I can stop the feeling how are we
gonna hug our way out of this one I will
protect you no matter what
pinky promise you can't go back on a
pinky
Oh pinkie promise a smooth jazz troll
daily paralyzed
[Music]
you